[Music]
that's cardi b her hubby offset and
their daughter culture recording voice
overs for their cameo on the animated
nickelodeon series baby sharks big show
it's true cardi b is turning into sharky
b
on thursday the 29 year old rapper
shared a tease of her fishy new role i
got here by doing things my own sharky
bee way
but cardi didn't want to go on this
ocean voyage alone so she's bringing her
family along for the ride
[Music]
really loud and excited yay sharky
say yay sharky yay
and that adorable moment turned into
this
that's the entire fam as animated sharks
offsets looks pretty spot on it's a
blessing for god and the grammy winner's
latest gig should come as no surprise
cardi's been a vocal baby shark fan
since the beginning remember this viral
moment from
[Music]
yep 2019 the bodak yellow rapper doing a
runway walk around a pool set to the
popular song at the time cardi tweeted
that baby culture loved the whole baby
shark mixtape so it's safe to say that
now three-year-old's dreams came true
she's so cute i love her but back to the
show it wouldn't be a cardi b guest
appearance without some music the
special episode will also feature a new
song from the best rapper under the sea
sharky b the title the seaweed sway
[Music]
[Applause]
but don't worry cardi is still making
hits for the grown-ups too oh yes honey
check out the music video for her latest
single a collab with summer walker and
scissor called no
[Music]
as love cardi's next project let's hope
it's with bts because culture she's a
big fan i know my daughter she she loves
bts i like her to listen to bts because
you know they're like more like
friendly and they make her dance and all
that stuff and when the k-pop group
found out the three-year-old is part of
the bts army they had a special message
for her oh good career
hey
let's do it again
you know what's up that's the culture
right there let's go until the collab
between cardi and bts happens we'll be
playing this one on repeat say yay
sharky
yeah
really loud and excited yay sharky
say yay sharky yay
[Music]